[Musique]
principal demeure de l'écrivain
alexandre dumas le domaine de monte
cristo est composé du château d'if et de
son cabinet de travail dès le 19 mai le
château de monte-cristo va rouvrir ses
portes et pouvoir accueillir de nouveau
du public avec une jauge la jauge dans
le parc n'est pas limité en revanche
elle le sera dans le château donc comme
l'an dernier quand on a rouvert en juin
2020 on a rouvert avec 30 personnes
autorisées en simultané dans le château
le parc du château avait déjà rouvert à
quelques privilégiés pour des visites
guidées sur réservation
par groupe de 5 maximum ses très bonnes
occasions parce que effectivement à deux
personnes à voir le parc pour nous tout
seul c'était vraiment intéressant on
avait le temps de voir de discuter avec
la conférencière et de mieux comprendre
le site fermé depuis plus de six mois la
directrice du château a vu son nombre de
visites annuelles dégringolé en principe
sur une année on a entre 25000 et 30000
visiteurs sur une année là nous sommes
bientôt bientôt fin mai et on en aura eu
zéro pour le moment pas non peut-être
avec les petites visites quelques jours
il s'est vraiment rien par rapport à la
fréquentation habituelle le château qui
travaille avec de nombreux artistes
prévoit de les retrouver rapidement le
dimanche 13 juin organise une après midi
musical on va avoir une harpiste qui va
venir faire différentes compositions et
puis on aura aussi un quartet de jazz
manouche qui sera présent tout va se
passer dans le parc
donc ça ira très bien sur le plan
sanitaire
un retour à la normale est donc prévue
pour le 19 mai puisque le château de
monte-cristo rouvrira selon les horaires
habituels du mardi au dimanche et
alexandrine la mascotte du domaine
attend les visiteurs nombreux